Guten Abend, demir ist mein Name.
Ja, guten Abend.
Ich bin der erste Arzt in der Arzt auf dieser Station.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Julius Becker.
Julius Becker.
Herr Becker, könnt ihr Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen langsam bestabilen?
Julius wird geschrieben, J. Ulrich Ludwig Ida Ulrich Siegfried.
Ulrich Siegfried, Julius.
Ja, Julius.
Und nachname Becker, Bertha, Emil, Caesar, Kaufmann, Emil, Richard.
Herr Becker, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 49 Jahre alt.
Waren Sie sich genau geboren?
Am 10. August 1975.
Ja, okay, Herr Becker.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Und zwar, von dem ich habe seit drei Tagen Schmerzen im Bereich meiner Halswirbelsäule,
die Schmerzen strahlen in meinen rechten Arm aus.
Und seit heute ist es so, dass ich ein bisschen,
ich habe schon Kraft, aber ein bisschen Kraftverlust habe in meinem rechten Arm.
Seit wann haben Sie die Becherbe schmerzen?
Seit drei Tagen.
Seit drei Tagen habe ich Schmerzen in meinem Lackenbereich, die in meinem Arm auskommt.
Und seit heute habe ich das Problem,
dass ich nicht mehr so viel Kraft habe bei einem rechten Arm.
Okay, ich verstehe, Herr Becker.
Gleichgradiger Kraftverlust.
Könnten Sie mir genau bescheiden, sind die Schmerzen drumpfende, stehende
oder krampartige?
Ich würde sagen, das so ziehen der Schmerz.
Sind die Schmerzen pröstlich aufgetretet oder langsam?
Die Schmerzen, nee, also vor drei Tagen haben die so langsam, also ich bin wohnens aufgewacht
und da hatte ich die Schmerzen gehabt sozusagen.
Und die waren dann immer mehr zugenommen, also im Laufe des Tages haben die dann zugenommen.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen bei der Schmerz,
oder wobei ein sehr lecker Schmerz uns sehen, stärker Schmerz entspricht?
Ich würde sagen sieben.
Halten Sie die Schmerzen bis Ende des Gesprächs aus
oder machen Sie etwas in etwas...
Nee, wir können weiter reden.
Okay, ja, ich verstehe, Herr Becker.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine schwere Dinge angehoben?
Schwere Sachen mit den Angogen? Nein.
Nein.
Ist Ihnen ein Taubheitsgefühl Kräben aufgefallen?
Nein, ist nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie eine Bewegung Einschreckung aufgefallen?
Bewegung Einschreckung, ja, also bewegen kann ich, aber ich habe nicht mehr so viel Kraft
im Vergleich zu meinem linken Arm.
Ja.
Kraftschwäch, also Muskelschwächung, würde ich sagen.
Haben Sie Überkeit?
Überkeit, nein, habe ich nicht.
Müssten Sie erübergreifen?
Ich habe keine Überkeit, aber ich muss auch nicht übergeben, nicht.
Ist Ihnen Herr Schrazan Herr Stolptan bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Herr Doktor, eine Frage, was hat es mit meinen Schmerzen zu tun?
Sie haben Übelkeit oder Herz?
Ja.
Hat es mit meinen Schmerzen im Wackenbereich zu tun?
Ja, manchmal hat es Probleme oder magene Probleme.
Ich habe keine Überreifen, aber ich muss diese Frage stellen.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Atemnot habe ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich february?
Nein.
Haben Sie gegen diese Beschwerde ein Medikament eingehauen?
Ja.
Welche Medikament habe ich eingehauen?
Auf jeden Fall habe ich zu Hause 600 Millikamten.
600 Millikamten.
Hat das Medikament Ihre geholfen?
Ja, das hat so ein bisschen meine Schmerzen gelindert.
Gelindert, verstehe.
Ich möchte auch fragen, haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Ähnliche Beschwerden?
Ja, hatte ich schon mal gehabt vor zwei, drei Jahren, aber die waren nicht so schlimm.
Da hat auch keine Schmerzausstrahlung in den Armen gehabt,
also nur nacken Schmerzen gehabt vor zwei, drei Jahren.
Waren Sie für diese Beschwerde beim Arzt gewesen?
Nein, damals habe ich auch über Profing genommen und da war es gut, nach ein paar Tagen.
Hat sich Ihre Beschwerde im Verlauf verschreitet oder geholfen?
Nein, eine leichte Verstärkung, würde ich sagen.
Also in den letzten drei Tagen meinten Sie, leichte Zunahme der Beschwerden.
Herr Höbecker, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlösen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie in der Restzeit ab und zu genommen haben?
Ab oder zu genommen haben?
Ich bin ungefähr gleich gewöhnt geblieben.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Höbecker?
Ich bin 1,81 m groß.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
92 kg, kann man sagen.
92 kg.
Herr Höbecker,
sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ich meine Bluthochduch- und Loxotokrankheit,
schippt du unter der Funktion?
Ja, ich nehme Medikamente ein wegen Bluthochducherkrankung.
Welche Medikamente?
Das heißt Ramipril, 10 mg, dann nehme ich morgens eine ein.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Erkrankungen?
Seit 3 Jahren, circa.
Gibt es noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ich nehme noch Medikamente wegen meinen erhöhten Cholesterinwert,
nehme ich Medikamente ein.
Welche Medikamente nennen Sie?
20 mg, abends eine.
Seit wann leiden Sie an Erkrankungen?
Auch circa 3 Jahre.
Gibt es noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Herr Höbecker, ist bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Nein.
Wundern Sie schon mal obverredet?
Herr Höbecker, rauchen Sie?
Auch nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja.
2-3 Mal in der Woche ein Glas Wein trinke ich schon zum Essen.
Ja, ein Glas Wein.
Herr Höbecker, ich nehme an, dass Sie keine Drogen nehmen, oder?
Nein, habe ich nie genommen.
Herr Höbecker, sind Sie gegen Corona-Hepatitis oder Kinderkrankheit gegräft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
War Sie in der Westerzeit im Ausland gewesen?
Letzte Zeit waren Sie letzten Sommer bei euch auf Mallorca gewesen.
Mallorca?
Herr Höbecker, ich möchte ein paar Fragen bei Ihrer Familie stellen.
Haben Ihre Eltern irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Ja, mein Vater hat Bluthochdruckerkrankungen, soweit ich weiß.
Soweit ich weiß?
Soweit ich weiß, also ich kenne hier alle Erkrankungen.
Da weiß ich nur, dass er Bluthochdruckerkrankungen hat,
weil wir darüber reden, sonst weiß ich da nichts.
Meine Mutter nimmt Spritze wegen dem erhöhten Zuckerwert.
Eine authentische Zuckerwert.
Sie hat Spritzen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Erkrankungen zählen, sie ist auch übergewichtig.
Aber Sie geschwistert?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Soweit ich weiß, ja.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Bleiben Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, wir wohnen, haben noch zwei Kinder, mit meiner Frau,
wir sind alle zusammen.
Sind Sie gesund?
Wer?
Die Kinder, die Frau.
Ja, alle sind gesund, soweit ich weiß.
Was machen Sie von der Uhr?
Ich bin Zollbeanter.
Bitte?
Aber dann ruckwachen?
Ja.
Herr Becker, ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seit drei Tagen Nackenschmerzen.
Sie haben sich auf die schmerzen Strahlen recht.
Im Verlauf verschwärzt sich die Schmerzen.
Sie haben auch Kraft verliebt.
Ich habe für mich alle wichtige Fragen.
Wollen Sie etwas hinzuführen?
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, dass ich einen Kraftverlust habe.
Aber Sie haben nicht gesagt, wo.
Man kann ja Nackenschmerzen mit auftragenden Armen haben
und Kraftverlust zu einem Fuß haben.
Das war am Arm?
Ja, Arm.
Ich wollte es etwas präzisieren.
Sonst passt das.
Ich wollte noch die letzte Frage stellen.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Ein Unfall habe ich nicht gehabt.
Nein, in der letzten Zeit nicht.
Sie sind schmerzendauerhaft.
Sie sind schmerzendauerhaft?
Ja, seit drei Tagen.
Danke, Doktor.
Wie geht es denn weiter?
Was habe ich denn gemacht?
Herr Becker, ich vermute, dass Sie eine Erdenprobleme haben.
Aber das ist eigentlich etwas,
das ich zuerst die Körperhüter untersuchen.
Danach brauchen wir Lobo- und Bildgebände untersuchen.
Wenn wir alle Ergebnisse erlangen,
werden wir das weitere Problem beitragen.
Sie nehmen Sie bitte Platz.
Ich komme gleich.
Danke schön, Herr Doktor.
Haben Leute Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie Kraftverlust beim Greifen oder Halten?
Wenn ich mein Arm zumiert ziehe,
dann habe ich meinen Bezirksgericht.
Sie haben keine Kraftverlust im Finger.
Ich habe den Finger nicht auf meinem Ellenbogen.
Bei den Beugen meines Ellenbogens.
Danke.
Hallo.
Hat jemand weitere Fragen?
Haben Sie Gestörungen?
Nein.
Haben Sie gestauter Halswänen bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Können Sie irgendeine Naken in alle Richtungen bewegen?
Ich habe eine Halswäbelseule.
Ich kann es bewegen, aber wenn ich nach rechts drehe,
ist es eingeschränkt.
Schmerzhaft eingeschränkt.
Ich kann drehen, aber es tut weh.
Herr Kollege, brauchen Sie es?
Nein, ich möchte noch.
Ich kann mich anfangen.
Dann kann ich vielleicht noch mal stoppen.
Die 1,5 Minuten ist da.
Geht das?
Los geht es.
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Er heißt Julius Mecker.
Er ist 49 Jahre alt.
Er kam zu uns wegen,
seit 3 Tagen bestehende,
siehende und tunemende Schmerz,
Naken-Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in den Rechten ab.
Der Patient berichtet,
dass die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten sind.
Darüber hinaus berichtet der Patient,
dass die Schmerzen dauerhaft sind.
Die Schmerzen liegen bei 7,10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Darüber hinaus gibt der Patient an,
dass sie die Schmerzen im Rechten oberenextrinten haben.
Die Frage nach Arstisi,
womit es nausea und Herzprobleme wurden verneint.
Außerdem gibt der Patient an,
dass sie gegen diese Schmerzen
Ibuprofen 600 Milligramm eingenommen haben
und das Medikament hat ihm geholfen.
In der Vegetativenanlage ist unaufhörig,
andere Vorerkrankungen sind arteriale Hypertomie
und Hypertkulistromemie bekannt.
Der Patient leidet seit 3 Jahren arteriale Hypertomie
und er nimmt 7 Milligramm morgens ein
und er nimmt auch 27 Milligramm abends.
Seit 3 Jahren.
Allergen sind unbekannt, nicht bekannt
und bislang ist der Patient bislang
keine Operationen erpuppt.
Die Kotinkonsum wurde verneint
und Herr Becker trägt 2-3 Glas Wein pro Woche
und der Drugkonsum wurde verneint.
Im Funkstatus und Reisananlage ist unaufhörig.
In der Familienanlage hat sein Vater
arteriale Hypertomie und seine Mutter
hat Diabetes mellitus
Der Patient hat einen gesunden Bruder
und er ist verheiratet und hat 2 Gesunde Kinder.
Der Patient arbeitet als Solbeamter
und hat ein kleines Subtom
und eine Anämnese durch den Amnest
Stereokalertiskussrolapsus hin.
Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen
folgende Erkrankungen.
Muskelverschüpfelung,
Spinaldegenerative Erkrankungen.
Wo und wann fahren Sie mit der Erkrankung?
Selbkalt Spinalkonaxthenose.
Im welchen Bereich?
Sie sagen ja nur,
eventuell, dass da die degenerative Erkrankung wäre,
dann sollte es auch Ruhe sein.
Also eine Haltschöresolle.
Was kennen Sie da als einige Beispiele?
Spinalkanalthenose haben Sie gesagt,
eine, was noch,
eine aus der Perose.
Würde aus der Perose Schmerzen machen?
Nein, nein.
Oder wie bei so einer Praktur?
Praktur, ja, kann es auch sein.
Oder Rufenmachs Erkrankungen,
Spinalkort Erkrankungen wie Syringomile.
Kann auch diese machen.
Weiter.
Ihr Verdacht, ja,
Hauptgedacht, Thenose ist ein
Zervikalaban-Scherferfall.
Oder Prolaps.
Sollte sich die Verdacht auf Zervikalaban-Scherferfall
prolapses einverhalten,
würde ich folgende Therapie vorschlagen.
Würden Sie direkt zur Therapie gehen?
Oder würden Sie nachweisen,
ob das wirklich so ist?
Oder ausschließen, ob etwas anderes wäre?
Ja, so erst würde ich
Körperbeschandte besuchen.
Bei den Körperbeschandte
würde ich Muskelkraft
lauthalten.
Und
dann würde ich
Blutlabo
beurteilen.
Bei den Blutlabo würde ich
Blutbild, CRP
und BSC
ütieren.
Als bildgebende Verfahren würde ich
schon kennen, das heißt, wie man solle
Schwaben und MFT
als wir bei solle
veranlassten.
Sollte sich die Verdacht auf
zervikalables prolapses
ütieren, würde ich
folgende Therapie vorschlagen.
Zuerst würde ich
nichts zu redeln,
sondern auch zu spät.
Ich würde auch
Vitamin B12
verabreichen.
Ich würde auch
Physiotherapie
veranlassen.
Laut der MRT-Befunde
und
Therapieergebnisse würde ich
mit dem Verfahren
operativ vorschlagen.
Bei
Röntgen
ist es
eine Röntgenaufnahme
zu erkennen.
Oder wenn Sie eine Röntgenaufnahme
in zwei Ebenen durchschönen lassen,
dann könnten Sie ausschließen?
Was kann man in Röntgen sehen?
Welche Erkrankungen
können Sie sehen oder nicht sehen?
Ich schließe
aus, ob
eine Wirbelsäule
fragtüft gibt
oder Dislocation gibt.
Man könnte etwas noch sehen.
Leidwirbel
würden Sie das lateinisch nennen?
Die Stilistäse
Röntgen kann man
indirekt auch etwas sagen.
Über den Bandscheibenfach, wenn der sich
verändert,
dann kann man
eine Ostschundrose erkennen.
Wenn der Bandscheibenfach weniger wird,
dann kann man die
Gelenkfläche, der über die
Röntgenaufnahme,
die
Übergang zwischen Bandscheiben und Knochen
nicht regelmäßig ist,
eine Ostschundrose sehen.
Aber ein Bandscheibenvorfall, können wir das sehen?
Nein.
Wie können Sie das verwenden?
Welche Aufnahmen
würden Sie sonst veranlassen?
Sie haben gesagt, es ist ein Bandscheibenvorfall.
Es ist eine gefährliche Untersuchung?
Nein, das ist keine
gefährliche Untersuchung.
Aber mit den beiden MRT
können wir weich teilen
das organische Beruf teilen.
Besonders Spinalcourt, Bandscheiben
und Bindegewebe.
Das ist eine gefährliche Untersuchung.
Bindegewebe teilen.
Ok, gut.
Von meiner Seite aus,
haben Sie Fragen?
Hat jemand in der Gruppe Fragen?
Kann jemand etwas ergänzen?
Man kann auch sagen,
dass diese alle differenzialen Diagnose sind.
Nein, das ist sehr komplex.
Du kannst es sagen, das ist eine sehr komplexe Band-Charm für die Alberta Disco Scrollabs.
Aber die Scrollabs erzählen es schon.
Du kannst mir ein weiteres Programm zeigen.
Wenn wir in der Türkei ein Band-Charm haben,
wenn wir in der Türkei ein Band-Charm haben,
dann wird es ein extra Disco-Roller.
Das wird ein extra Disco-Roller.
Dann wird es ein extra Disco-Roller.
oder die Zächer, die die Zächer verabschieden.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Können Sie noch einmal beschreiben,
diese Aufdruckschritte?
Welches?
bei der zwischen der unterschied zwischen Bandscheid vor Wölkung und vor Fall besteht darin,
dass die Bandscheibe besteht aus einer Kapsel und einem galertigen Inhalt.
Wenn die Kapsel nicht mehr in Takt ist, dann nennt man eine Vorwölbung, also Veränderung der Bandschabstruktur
im Berichtung des Kanals, nennt man dann eine Vorwölbung und wenn die Kapsel nicht mehr in Takt ist,
dann tritt der galertige Inhalt nach außen aus.
Das Austreten dieser galertigen Inhalts nennt man dann ein Bandscheiben vor Fall,
oder ein Diskus Prolaps oder ein Bandscheim Prolaps.
Dateinisch oder Deutsch, Datein Deutsch kann man das sagen, wie man es möchte.
Als Differenzialdiagnosen an der Hasfiebersäule würde ich generell, kann man immer sagen,
einmal eine Facettengelenksartrose zum Beispiel, ein Schmerz kann auch mit Aufstrahlung auftreten
oder Spinalkalansternose, Spondylylistesis und Osteoschondrose können auch Problem machen
oder Neuroforamensternosen sozusagen.
Oder extrem wäre zum Beispiel fragturen, pathologische Frakturen, zum Beispiel fragturen durch Tumor bedingt
oder auch wie der Kollege vorhin sagte, dass man im Spinal irgendwelche Erkrankungen hat,
Syringo, Myolytis oder sowas in der Richtung.
Also, was eher nicht orthopedisch, sondern eher neurologisch Erkrankungen sind
oder neurologisch Erkrankungen sind.